there's no time
13 o clock hey you guys it's episode 128
yeah what we got today we're doing more
true crime today one of these was a
request by a listener the toy box killer
okay and I thought that I'd also been
wanting to do the beauty queen killer
for a while too and since these are kind
of similar offenders and thankfully
they're both dead so I figured I would
put them together on one particular show
okay so we're gonna do those two I
should say the toy box killer even
though he's called the toy box killer
they're not sure if he killed anyone
they're pretty sure that he did kill
people but they never found any bodies
you know what I mean he was more he was
convicted of like rape and torture and
stuff like that but okay they never did
find any bodies but they're pretty sure
that he killed a bunch of people well
were there people missing yeah okay so
they just the fact they never found them
they so they just go on to call him
killer cuz they're just like yeah we're
just assuming oh yeah so those are the
two cases that we're gonna talk about
today before we do that I don't really
have that many shout outs other than you
know just like I say every time faceless
villain 2 is out on audiobook and thank
you to everybody that has purchased a
copy and also if you liked it please
leave a review if you haven't already
there it's very helpful I'm actually
going to be re-recording Volume one
probably in a week or two you know so I
don't know how long it's gonna take it
probably won't take as long as the
second one because I've read it so many
times and it's only like half the length
although by the time this gets out that
may may have already be under way it
should yeah because you know that's kind
of next on the agenda like after I
record this show so hopefully by the
time this episode comes out yeah it'll
be under way under way or like at least
kind
close to completion so that'll be not to
look forward to yeah also I think let's
see the only other thing was our last
movie review which was man with two
brains comedy we don't do a lot of those
so go check that out if you haven't seen
it also I think I've mentioned in the
last couple shows that I'm starting to
interact more on patreon
giving patrons like a day early they get
early access to all the shows so you
know I put a link on there so you can
watch them the day before everybody else
gets to see him somebody asked about
Instagram yeah I know it's like I really
really do need to get around to that
because it's like I've had believe me I
have Michael from a starry night it's
like always crawling on my ass about
doing doing Instagram and I'm like I
know I should it's like so many people
are on Instagram but it's like God it's
like yet another thing that I have to
figure out a do and it's just like I
haven't the time but I think eventually
I'll probably get around how would that
help how would that help our listeners
that were on Instagram well it's just
both I mean it's just like another
version of Facebook kind of right yeah
so I don't know eventually I'll probably
get around to it um one thing I did get
around to was I actually redesigned my
website and redesigned my blog to kind
of look more moderate and have newer
photos and blah-dee-blah
changed the design a little bit so I got
a new intro - yeah well we've only had
this one for like a year right yeah this
is the new one is from last year
eventually we had to get another one
it's a good one but supposed to change
them out every year because I like that
one in it and you know and like I said
it's I've already got a million other
things to do and I just I never get
around to do and like that okay but
alright well I might it's just you know
when I have time I'll do it okay you
know what I mean I don't I've got a but
yeah so yeah and I've I've been trying
to interact more on patreon if you guys
haven't noticed like I said I put the
early links up there
I give like heads up
what the week's topics are gonna be like
a couple days ahead of time and you know
posting videos I think I put one up of
deer and so go check that out if you
want to become a patron that would be
super cool and we would really
appreciate it okay so that's about I
think that's about all the shoutouts
that
we have so let's kind of start talking
about the toy box killer all right
otherwise known as David Parker ray
that's the dude's name okay now like I
said he was ultimately convicted of rape
and torture and not of murder because
they never did find any bodies but they
are presuming from because he had
accomplices a couple of whom were women
one of whom was his daughter and one of
whom was his girlfriend was this this
was um actually out in air in New Mexico
and also in Arizona now they think that
from you know people that went missing
around that area knowing his modus
operandi and from talking to his various
accomplices police are speculating that
he may have killed as many as 60 I think
I know you're talking about now yes you
talk about the guy they had the trailer
and they need brainwash him and let him
go some of them
he didn't brainwash them II drug the
drug right yeah so mostly so they
wouldn't remember that go member yeah
yeah David Parker ray he's sick the dogs
on him too yeah yeah I remember that
yeah this this guy was really [ __ ]
yeah
so no his daughter was involved in that
yeah but I mean yeah we'll get to that
this is these these two dudes are just I
mean you know we talk about a lot of
scumbag serial killers and a lot of
scumbag murders and stuff but these -
yeah big scumbag okay
these are back in the 90s then right
yeah yeah but he had been doing it for a
really like I said they don't even know
how long he was doing it for so they
call him the toy box killer as you said
because he you know after they caught
him they discovered that on his property
which was in New Mexico in that place
called Elephant Butte yeah it's right
near Truth or Consequences New Mexico
but he had on his property he had this
big trailer that he apparently spent a
hundred thousand dollars soundproofing
yeah and equipping with all kinds of fun
torture equipment you've got a lot of
gynecological chair yeah kind of whips
it he built he got a head it had like
disco lights and I don't know I think
you had disco lights and sound system
too you know the pictures that I saw of
it it's just like yeah because he had
been a mechanic so he knew how to like
build all these particular yeah toy like
he would build things to like shock
people and it's like from what I
remember this case he had basically like
a little mini video studio and
everything that he would record this
stuff yeah that's how I remembered it
yeah he did record it and he also had a
mirror on the ceiling so that his
victims could watch what he was doing to
them while he was doing it so yeah so
yeah this guy the David Parker ray born
in 1939 now his parents were allegedly
abusive his dad left when he was only 10
years old he had a sister named Peggy
but she doesn't really figure to the
story all that much so after the dad
left him and his sister ended up going
and living with their grandparents and
this was in Mountainair New Mexico now
their grandparents were hard-asses real
disciplinarian blah-dee-blah which you
know that doesn't work out so good when
you have some kid with this particular
proclivity so the grandfather would like
beat up the kids and all this other kind
of crap David also was didn't do too
well in school he was real like kind of
awkward looking and he was really quiet
people thought he was a weirdo right he
was but so you know he wasn't like
popular girls I mean he used to get
bullied and stuff like that so that was
kind of another thing that was going on
and he kind of got into drugs and
drinking and stuff to kind of you know
get out of the pain or whatever now
around this time apparently he started
his fascination with sadomasochism now
some of the sources that I saw said that
every now and then like his drunk ass
dad would you know bumble into town to
like see his kids you know once every
couple years or something like that
and go hey here kid I brought you a big
bag of S&M magazines knock yourself out
hmm so you know we were well that's how
it is in their family yeah thanks dad
give me a big [ __ ] thing yeah and
they were like this was like you know
the old school ones that were like I
don't even know how consenting some of
those women in the photos were you know
what I mean it was like that kind of
[ __ ] so yeah so the dad would do that um
so after he gets out of high school he
actually joined the army and he was in
the army an honorable discharge all that
kind of crap he also worked as an auto
mechanic and as an airplane mechanic I
believe in the army he did a mechanic
work while he was in the army now
they're not really sure when his crimes
great spree might have begun later on
somebody because he ended up actually
over the years he ended up being married
a bunch of times i he was only married
like he was married four times I think
and like the last one was like four ten
years so it's not you know what I mean
yeah um so I don't know how much of this
[ __ ] was going on when he was married or
if it was just something he did on the
sly or I don't know but apparently one
of his wives or his fiancee or something
like that he apparently told her that
his first victim was when he was still a
teenager it was like a girl or a an
older woman who he like kidnapped and
like tired her to a tree and tortured
her and murdered her and this was when
he was still pretty young so I don't
know they never did find any crime
you know correspondent to that so I
don't know but yeah he might have made
that up but like I said you know from
all the you know his accomplices
statements and from you know trying to
figure out like women that went missing
in Perth this particular area and when
he was living there and stuff like that
they do think that he killed people they
just don't know where the bodies are you
know what I mean
he's pretty methodical from what I
remember highly organized yes and like I
said he had help
yeah now for a long time he was just
living in this [ __ ] [ __ ] he actually
he was a mechanic but then later on he
started working at the Elephant Butte
State Park he was like a forestry Ranger
somebody didn't I just say that on the
show about Son of Sam that that is
weirdly because remember when I said
about the the most common jobs of serial
killers and for some reason like
forestry worker type [ __ ] was on there
and I'm like that seems oddly specific
maybe something that attracts them maybe
maybe it's like they like being out in
the middle of nowhere and they know like
they like knowing all the woods that's
what I'm saying and that's another thing
that makes them think that you know
probably and also where he lived maybe
their outdoor type guys anyway yeah and
with so they could just kind of get
channeled into that yeah plus he was a
veteran you said so yeah he would have
had preference in the hiring process
yeah so you know just gravitated in that
direction yes so there was that little
thing about him like you know working in
a state park and also where he lived
like his property was right near this
huge body of water like a big reservoir
so I mean the reservoir has been
searched but they're like it's way too
big and too deep to like you know search
it super effectively but they're
speculating that there are probably some
bodies in there because well I saw a
documentary about it and like one of the
investigators on the case was just like
you can't just have this here right here
where this dude is like torturing and
raping people and not have bodies in
there he's like there's just gotta be
bodies in there we just haven't found
them
yeah so yeah so they're not sure when
his [ __ ] started and all this stuff was
going on all this the whole time now he
didn't get caught no one had any idea
that he was up to any of this [ __ ] and
people um that knew him like that worked
with him and later on like after he got
caught they were like amazed they were
just like oh he was such a nice man you
know what I mean they just couldn't
believe it so he was pretty good at
keeping the [ __ ] on the down-low I guess
so they didn't catch him until 1999 and
this is how he got caught this is March
22nd 1999 again in Elephant Butte I just
keep saying cuz I like it because it
looks like elephant butt but it has a
beautiful no Butte is like a it's like a
um what do you call it it's like a
landscape feature it's kind of like a
Mesa in the horse world Butte is like a
drug like aspirin yeah horses okay no
it's like a I want to say it's like a
Mesa okay but it's kind of you know what
I mean it's kind of that kind of thing
so March 22nd 1999 this 22-year old girl
named Cynthia V Hill and I think I'm
pronouncing it right it looks like vigil
it spelled like vigil but when like
every time I saw like a documentary
about they pronounced it V Hill so I
guess that's how you pronounce it so she
is running down the street was she's
naked covered in blood has like a metal
dog collar on and dragon like a chain
behind her yeah she busts into this
person's double-wide trailer and it's
like I got kidnapped and raped and
tortured please help me and the person
was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] there's like
bloody naked woman just like burst into
the house oh they called the cops the
cops come there and so then she tells
them what happened now she had actually
been a prostitute and she said that she
was approached by a man and a woman and
the man said that he asked for oral sex
he said I'll give you $20
get in my RV so she didn't think much of
it because like I said he had a woman
with him so that's her job so you know
right yeah and so that so she gets in
there and once she gets inside the they
tie her up and gag her and everything
like to put the metal thing around her
neck and like cover her eyes up and
stuff so then they drive for about an
hour and then they dragged her inside a
trailer chained her to a bedpost and
then and this is so [ __ ] creepy and
like I heard some of this to this
[ __ ] David Parker ray he has made an
audio tape of himself describing what
he's going to do to the victim this is
how many [ __ ] victims he's had that
he's like he can't even be bothered to
like come in there and like tell them
hey I'm gonna do this that and the other
he put it on a [ __ ] audio tape so he
can just click play maximum efficiency
got tired of giving that monologue I
guess and it's like I couldn't listen to
the whole tape cuz I'm just like this
elector press I heard like the pan it
starts out like hey [ __ ] yeah yeah you
know like if you're listening to this
tape it means I picked up another hooker
like some other [ __ ] like that I'm like
it's pretty tacky it's yeah he's like a
toe it's like there's goodies like
there's to be other captives in there
don't look to them for any help they
can't help you yeah he usually had more
than one at the same time and so he's
like okay well you aren't to speak
unless spoken to it's like you have to
call me master and you have to call this
other woman mistress we're gonna like
you know you have to do whatever we say
we're gonna feed you like a dog like on
the floor and all this other kind of
crap it's sex with dogs yeah well that
yeah and that was another thing too it's
like this poor woman that yeah she said
she was chained up they fed her from a
bowl on the floor like a dog they would
invite people over like they had this
wooden contraption that would like and
then they'd strap you to us who you were
you know like bent over it and then he
would invite friends over to rape her he
would let his dogs rape her basically
it's just like ever I D the friends
one of them and he thought they were it
was all consensual BDSM he knew that
they were captives I'm not really sure
actually he go down for it go to prison
do you know one of them did yeah but but
yeah some of the others there was
actually speculation that there were
like cops involved or anything like that
but I couldn't really find a lot of
evidence of that obviously but um yeah
so so she had like the most horrible
[ __ ] she had like every conceivable
thing like stuffed in every conceivable
orifice and it's just like this
horrifying horrifying [ __ ] so she's been
chained up for three days in this
[ __ ] scumbags house now
one day oh and he had cattle prods and
[ __ ] like that too and like I said he
would shock them and it's just so
alright
so David Parker ray he goes to work one
day as he usually did now he left the
woman there to look after her but
apparently the woman like toddled off
into the kitchen to make a sandwich or
something like that yeah and she
accidentally left the keys to the to the
handcuffs like right where Cynthia could
get them and she was like she's now yeah
so she snatched him up and like started
unlocking and she got a phone and called
9-1-1 but then the woman mistress she
comes rushing in as like nah and they
start fighting now Cynthia and I was
like you [ __ ] go girl
she found a [ __ ] ice pick and she
stabbed that [ __ ] in the back neck she
didn't kill her it's in a killer but um
you know it made her like fall down and
she you know and so then she's like she
got the [ __ ] out of there she's wet she
didn't even give [ __ ] she was naked and
covered with blood she just went running
down the [ __ ] Street
ran about a mile and turned up in the
trailer where she was found and actually
the the 9-1-1 they had had the phone
call that she had made you know the
woman had come storming in there and so
it was a hang-up but even though it's a
hang-up the police are still gonna
investigate that [ __ ] because they
figure oh somebody snatched the phone
out of her hand so they went there so
when she went to the other trailer you
we're the rescuer was that woman called
9-1-1 too
so like the cops just descended so they
knew the address of the trailer and they
already went there now they went to the
trailer and no one was there however
only a couple of blocks from the trailer
they apprehended David Parker ray and
his girlfriend
whose name was Cindy Hendy now listen to
this [ __ ] [ __ ] story that they
gave because they were apparently like
out because they're like oh [ __ ] our sex
slave escaped and they were out looking
for her so the cops puller was like what
the [ __ ] and they were like oh yeah well
we were um we did kidnap her and we were
keeping her hostage
but it's cuz she is a heroin addict and
we were doing an intervention so we were
doing it for her own good yeah and I was
like and the cops were like I don't
think so
so yeah so they said the cops are like
via [ __ ] you guys and they arrested them
and then they start searching the
property and are completely horrified by
what they find so and it was sad because
like like I said I watched a couple
documentaries about this and like so the
investigating officers were just like
this is like a little bitty town I mean
Elephant Butte I think it was only like
1,500 people like lived there and
they're like the cops had never seen
anything like this before
they're like obviously this David Parker
ray guy it's like he has spent a great
deal of time and money like putting all
this [ __ ] together he's like it was
unbelievable he's like you go in this
[ __ ] trailer and he's just like the
walls are just like full is just like
all these different and instruments look
like a David Cronenberg movie in there
it's like he's got cattle prods and
oxygen tanks and he's got like medical
books and all this other kind of crap so
like so he knows the best way to torture
you like without you dying and also the
kind of crap and it's just like
horrifying they were horrified yeah and
when you look when you see the outside
of this place it kind of reminds me of a
place in that California called the
Salton Sea
yeah they have whole like documentaries
on this place it's like this
wastes light yes you know where it's a
wasteland weird place just look up the
salt and see there's old documentaries
on that's kind of what that area looked
like from what I remember yeah inside
his trailer
dusty dingy desert kind of play yeah
it's just a big desert yeah and like I
said it's you know Elephant Butte it's
not that far from Truth or Consequences
which is you know not a huge town either
but you know it's a bigger town this
place was just like a little town
they said that just sprung up around
this reservoir it's like it's kind of a
big tourist area they're like you know
sometimes during tourist season they can
get like hundreds of thousands of people
coming through there but they're like
only about 1,500 people live there look
like Bombay Beach yeah just Google
Bombay Beach it's at the Salton Sea kind
of look like that that's what I remember
so after so okay so they go through and
they find all this horrifying [ __ ] they
find actually among all the other
horrifying artifacts they find a
videotape of David Parker ray and his
girlfriend torturing another woman now
they don't know who this woman is
because her face was completely covered
in duct tape but she was like screaming
and everything on the tape and they were
just doing horrible [ __ ] to her but she
did have a very distinctive tattoo on
her leg so they were hoping that they
would be able to identify her so they
kind of made that public so there was
that whole thing now they wanted to know
because they said obviously this dude
has been at this a long time so this
can't be the only woman that he has done
this to so they told the media
everything about it and said you know we
want more victims you know to see if
anybody else has gone through this kind
of [ __ ] so the problem - and I know this
is terrible but you know Cynthia the
girl that escaped she was a prostitute
so they're just kind of like you know
credibility is an issue as it usually is
with sex workers so they were like well
we need more people that maybe aren't
prostitutes hopefully so when they
release it to the media they actually
did get a woman come forward her name
was Angelica Montano
and she said
they had done the same thing to her that
she I don't I don't think she was a
prostitute her she was doing anything
these two just kind of like tricked her
I think they got her out of a bar they
talked it no that was a that was a
different one I think well no it might
have been because they did pick up a lot
of people from this bar I think it's
called a blue waters saloon or something
like that yeah yeah there was pictures
of it in the documentary so they might
have got her from there but so yeah this
Angelica girl was kidnapped raped and
tortured she was in the toy box for
three days and then they drugged her and
just left her on the side of the highway
now she was found wandering around in
the desert and an off-duty cop found her
and she told him what had happened and
evidently he believed her but he's like
okay well we have to go to the police
and report this and she said she didn't
want to because she said she was afraid
of the police because of her past and
she didn't think they would believe her
and all this other stuff so that's that
was that story now she I think she said
that she did reported the cops and they
didn't do anything about it
he's too evidently what the guy would do
with him before he let him go is he'd
blindfold him and give him a bunch of
weird stuff like LSD and mind-altering
drugs and then put headphones on him
repeat phrases over and over again and
try to like Mindwipe them to make them
think that the whole thing was just a
hallucination and then let him go that's
how I remember I don't I didn't see
anything that said anything about that
but most of them from a documentary I
saw he gave him like your standard like
date rape drugs he would give him like
phenobarbital phenobarbital stuff like
that where where they wouldn't really
remember entirely what happened like I
see what he would pretty much briefie
them yeah now like I said the ones he
let go he would do that and I'm assuming
that he probably killed some of them too
because he did say to some of the
victims you know if you don't cooperate
or you try to escape I'll kill you so
they think that probably some of them
were killed I remember seeing a doctor
Triana they said that he was
brainwashing him before he let him go to
but that was just that one documentary
there yeah I didn't really see anything
that said that I mean there might have
been another dude that you're thinking
of to you oh it's busy when that okay
now at this stage they actually they
like I said they've the woman on the
videotape whose face you couldn't see
because it was covered with duct tape um
they put out a picture of her tattoo
like I said it was on her ankle it was
like a kind of a really nice like floral
tattoo um and they eventually discovered
this woman alive her name was Kelly
Garrett um so she actually came forward
now this is a [ __ ] shitty ass story
this is what happened to her so she had
just gotten married um in a couple days
after the wedding like her and her new
husband kind of got in a fight and she
got kind of pissed off so she's like man
I'm just gonna go hang out with my
friends cuz I'm sick of being sick of
looking at your face so she gets some of
her friends they go out to play pool or
whatever and they end up at this bar
this is the one I remember now she says
and she was interviewed and I was like
heartbroken watch this poor woman it's
like she had one beer and she didn't
finish it because she's like I drank
part of the beer and then one of my
friends you know wanted to a ride home
or something so I went to give her a
ride home and then I came back to the
bar now one of the friends that she was
with was Jesse ray David Parker Ray's
daughter yeah um this is scary because
she had known this woman for like three
years you know what I mean she's like I
had no reason to think that she would do
anything but apparently Jesse ray this
scumbags daughter drugged this poor
girl's beer yeah and kind of like sold
her to the dad or something yeah yeah
yeah yeah and it's like basically it's
like oh well you know I'll give you a
ride home and then she didn't remember
what happened and she's like the shitty
thing is that because you know she was
found like wandering around like three
days later and couldn't remember what
happened and she said for like a long
time afterward she kept um she kept
having these horrible horrible
nightmares and didn't know what they
were now this is the same girl in the
video that had the
tape all of her face yeah okay she has a
tattoo that's how they identify yes the
tape didn't really hurt her face they
pulled it off no okay she could but yes
um I think duct tape a damp pull every
bit of your hair off yeah well maybe it
said I don't know yeah
but so that's what [ __ ] kills me is
that this scumbags daughter he was
friends with this girl and just said oh
I'll drug her and take her back to daddy
so he can deal this horrible [ __ ] to her
the shitty thing too is that because
when they found her wandering around and
she didn't remember what had happened so
her husband
charming fellow that he was and his
parents thought oh well she must have
just run off and she was like on some
drug fuelled binge or she was like out
cheating on him so the husband like
kicked her out damn he thought she was
fooling around on it yeah and I mean and
she and she was like and I couldn't like
argue with him cuz I couldn't remember
what happened and she's like I knew I
was hurt she's like I knew I had
probably been raped she's like but I
didn't know where I was I didn't know
what had happened and all that other
time so that so that's just like [ __ ]
killed me that that happened at her but
she yes so she actually came forward and
she you know as they started as she
started like talking to the other
victims the police started talking to
her she started remembering she's like
oh well that's what all those nightmares
were that I thought were nightmares no
that [ __ ] really happened so that's
really nice so um once they arrested
David Parker ray and the girlfriend like
I said her name was Cindy Hendy now
Cindy just turned on him like
immediately right so she said yes like
not only did he do all this [ __ ] and I
helped but he told her that he had
killed 14 people that she knew of and
that just then that he had told her
where some of the bodies were now they
weren't able to find them so I don't
know like how accurate that information
is but but she did say that he had
confessed to her that he had killed at
least 14 people before he knew her
before before he knew her
because and like I said he was older he
was um I think when he was arrested he
was 59 okay so he was he'd been doing
this presumably for quite a long time
right so what made him stop killing he
didn't well she would have been with him
when during the time that he would have
killed the new ones yeah see that's the
thing I don't know I don't believe him I
don't know if he killed people when she
was with him and she didn't want to say
that or you know what I mean right so at
this stage Cindy Hendy also tells police
yeah
his daughter Jessie is also in on the
[ __ ] and there was another accomplice
named Dennis Roy Yancy now Dennis Roy
Yancy had apparently killed his
ex-girlfriend whose name was Marie
Parker so that so that was one murder
that they know like and Jesse was
probably was involved in that one too
Jesse's the daughter the daughter yeah
so that was at least one more and that
woman was missing so you know and they
didn't murder on the periphery
yeah it really linked it directly to the
main offender though no okay yeah so
evidently what what ended up happening
with that was that they arrested
Dennis Yancy and he confessed that he
said yeah
David Parker ray and Jesse the daughter
they kidnapped his ex-girlfriend Marie
Parker they say they put her in the toy
box she was in there for three days he's
like and then he got sick of her so he
asked me to kill her so he strangled her
evidently and then I don't know like
what he did with the body or anything
like that but like I said there was it's
the [ __ ] desert and there's like a
huge body of water and there's you know
so it could be anywhere and he told the
police that David Parker ray said that
he would kill me if I didn't do it in
yadda yadda so he actually got to 15
year sentences second-degree murder and
conspiracy to commit first-degree murder
the daughter said she didn't know
nothing about nothing and she just
wasn't even involved with anything and
blah blah blah but the cops didn't
really buy that and either Cindy Hendy
was she got 36 years because she did
admit to her part and like kidnapping
and raping and torturing um but she got
a little bit lighter sentence because
she testified against David Parker ray
and told about the accomplices and
everything like that
um the daughter was actually even though
she said that she didn't have anything
to do with him they found her guilty of
kidnapping
they sent Stern in nine years but six of
them she would be on parole so she would
only end up serving three but actually I
don't think she ended up serving any
because David Parker ray as part of his
plea deal he's like look I'll plead
guilty if you've let my daughter out hmm
so that's how that all went down like I
said Dennis Yancey actually he only
served 11 years because he did like
confess to a murder
but he violated his parole and then was
put back in prison let me I was for
actual murder of first-degree murder
they well I know but they were saying oh
well David Parker ray made me do it he
told me he was gonna kill me if I didn't
do it right
so I guess it was blank mitigating
circumstances so when it came to David
Parker ray they said okay well we're
gonna do three trials like one for each
of the victims that they could found
were Cynthia V Hill Angelica Montano and
Kelly Garrett it's the the creepy thing
was that when Cynthia V Hill when they
did her hearing they the lawyer like
puts the [ __ ] like metal collar and
the chain that they found her and like
they put it on the table like in front
of her and she just flipped the [ __ ] out
and she actually stood up I heard the
tape of it she stood up in court and
like just pointed him and said why the
[ __ ] did you do that to me you bastard
why did you and she was just like
screaming her [ __ ] hat off at him and
I'm like man good for you but they had
to take her outside and like you know
get the ambulance and [ __ ] like that see
if she could keep going but after that
when she came back in they calmed her
down and
she came back in and then David Parker
race it out I don't want to do three
trials all this others should all plead
guilty if you let my daughter out so
that's what they did he ended up getting
224 years um they actually couldn't have
gone ahead with the trial for Angelica
Montano anyway because she actually died
before the trial would have come would
have come along but here's the shitty
thing
so he gets 224 years but he only really
he didn't really serve any of that
sentence because he was still going back
and forth to various interrogations and
various trial post trial whatever's and
they're taken him to a state police
interrogation at Lee County Correctional
Facility in May of 2002 and he drops
dead of a heart attack [ __ ] yeah it's
like so he didn't even though he'd been
like in custody for like a year year and
a half or something like that yeah the
litigation stuff right yeah he didn't
serve any of that she didn't go to real
prison yeah yeah they said they just
like they put him in the room and then
all of a sudden he just [ __ ] slumped
over and he was [ __ ] dead massive
heart attack damn it's almost like you
did it on purpose
[ __ ] well he was probably under
a lot of stress cuz he got caught yeah
it was afraid to go to prison but can
you imagine like anyways well how old
was he at that time 59 he was almost 60
yeah he was from what I remember him he
was a weedy little nasty looking [ __ ]
yeah he looked he looked like a skinny I
don't think I don't think he was in very
good health you know I mean didn't look
super physically fit yeah to me so you
know eating a [ __ ] up diet and
everything get him died of a heart
attack clogged up arteries it's like
it's not like I wish he was still alive
but that seems like I'm like well you
got away with it basically everybody has
talked to everybody in this story pretty
much they were rough people these are
desert people and they're they're
low-income you know these are uh which
is gonna say they're these were a hearty
people yeah they they were kind of like
you know the Tusken Raiders
of America the Tusken Raiders the same
people yeah they're mean I like I kind
of it kills me whenever and I think I
mentioned this probably on our killer
couple show it always kills me when some
[ __ ] up dude
can get his wife or girlfriend yeah to
go along with this [ __ ] and like he now
apparently like I said he'd been married
a bunch of times before I don't really
know like if any of his former wives
knew of his proclivities or what he was
up to doing this very long I don't know
though because it does seem like I mean
from just the the breath of all the
stuff that they found like all the you
know toys that he'd made and like
machines that he'd made and like video
tapes and audio tapes and it seemed like
he'd been at it for a while I mean this
seemed like an obsession kind of reminds
me of humor of Charles Charles King and
his buddy remember Charles being the
guys that had the day Leonard Leonard
like that yeah we did a show kind of
like a Leonard Blake type of guy yeah
that's who I sit around and you
fantasize you have delusions of grandeur
and you go and you build things and you
build a bunker and and then you go brag
about how powerful you are to everybody
who knows you and then you kind of form
your own little cult which is basically
what Leonard Lake kind of did yeah yeah
it was a very similar kind of yeah was
her name cricket yeah they had cricket
it was kind of like a little mini three
or four man cult and this guy was he
always kind of struck me as kind of like
a Leonard Lake type yes yeah and it
really does seem like though I mean when
he met Cindy Hendy she had had a real
fucked-up childhood too she'd been
molested as a child and beaten as a
child and you know so she wasn't in the
best emotional state or mental health or
whatever and she was also into SNM but
it's just it's interesting how now
according to him he said she you know
she wasn't a murderer obviously
so he very slowly like introduced her to
the rape and torture thing that he was
it cuz it was a big thing for him he was
like super he had like he would write
about all these fantasies that he had
about it was like the main thing in his
life I remember the way I remember the
case I I haven't read anything about it
recently or seen anything on it but just
my impressions I remember thinking that
he hadn't really been doing this very
long I think that he was lying about it
you know I mean I don't think he had the
means and in order to make that because
it took him a while to make this this
dungeon that he had yeah he didn't have
that before yeah I think I think he
probably in reality maybe only abducted
but five six people maybe he killed two
one something like that I don't think he
claimed to have killed what 1516 yeah
he's bragging to his girlfriend I don't
think I don't believe so yeah that's why
I mean it's hard to say I mean when they
can't find any bodies and the couple
victims that they found were still alive
yeah he was a fantasize er yeah and
whenever you have a guy sits around
fantasize it makes this been you know
six big role-playing thing you know they
got a lie yeah big lie that's what they
do I think he hadn't been active at this
for very long and I'd really don't think
he had the skill to continue what he was
doing for very long until he would have
been caught that's what happened yeah
you know if you want to do something
like this and not get caught you have to
kill those victims yeah that's the
safest way you can't have him just
walking around yeah even if he drugged
him and he'd forgotten stuff no yeah you
know Leonard Blake had a better chance
and they did kill the Leonard Lake
killed a bunch oh yeah but they
eventually got caught - yeah most of
them do yeah so you know he was a bad
one but I don't think he killed as many
as he claimed yeah maybe not oh no yeah
like I said it's hard to say if he did
kill anybody the only one
- I think I'm thinking yeah because as
fixated he was in all this he would have
had a bunch of videotapes you know what
I mean he would have recorded what
happened with the other ones that he
killed he would have left stuff behind
yeah they couldn't find anything to link
him to any people that were the only
video tape I've ever heard of being
associated with him is that one of Kelly
Garrett we're not word so you know where
are all the other videotapes he had
video equipment it was set up like he
from when I remember he had like an
audio-visual like a lighting system and
everything's to light it up and goods in
a good stereo that's how I remembered it
yeah I mean he was it did look like he
was videotaping stuff because people
that escaped said that they remembered
so they're usually in some kind of
pattern where they do the exact same
thing every time you know I mean cuz
yeah I want to make a video gonna want
to make a videotape they can remember
the event by and you only had one yeah
which you know evidently you only had
one so that leads me to believe that he
hadn't been doing this for very long
yeah I think he planned it for a long
time to build up the courage to do it
and to get in the situation to do it you
know but I'm skeptical yeah maybe like
he said maybe just for a long time he
was just fantasized that yeah finally
and finally he started doing it when he
was you know in his 50s where he was in
a position financially and where he had
a place to do all this you know and ya
had the right social connections within
you know he had girls of you know the
girlfriend and a daughter and he had
friends they know and they were all kind
of being scumbags together in a certain
area he was able to kind of weasel his
way into this gig yeah yeah that's what
I think I heard that he knew like people
at that bar too and that they wouldn't
facilitate you know what I mean like
they knew what he was doing but they
would help out like hey there's this
girl that makes you skeptical what would
they have to gain from that I don't know
maybe cuz some bags gonna scum maybe
they bomb the take her for a ride that
type of deal well that's what I was
thinking because they did say that he
would invite people over and
rape the victims so maybe that's what
they maybe that's all they needed that's
just rare yes rare to get it's just like
a whole thing come join us in on this
serious felony we won't get caught it's
come join us on this serious felony yeah
I need a shirt that says that now that
was just a very funny way of phrasing
I'm gonna commit these serious felonies
you're not gonna just invite random
[ __ ] to come over and party
like just the bartender's just like that
sounds like you said it is man yeah well
these really don't sound like the
brightest bulbs I have to say so I'm not
discounting that because I've seen some
weird [ __ ] but you know I don't know and
like I said I don't think any of those
people were arrested dinner registers
they were doing [ __ ] like that they were
somehow rationalize it well yeah this is
all consensual that's probably when he
was saying yeah you know Bart culture
people knew he was into S&M brah so
maybe he would tell them ahead of time
oh well she's gonna sound like she don't
want to do it but that's just all part
of the game right exactly that's
probably how he sold it to him right
it's like yeah she'll be screaming and
[ __ ] but yeah she's into it she's into
it don't worry about it
like she loves this stuff that's
probably exactly what it was cuz think
how easy that would be to do yeah but
then you let him go like that nah dude
this dude that's doing this for real
he's not gonna let him go I wonder
though if he hadn't got caught if he
would have eventually started killing
him I imagine oh yeah if he didn't kill
any of the other ones like I said
they're pretty sure somebody killed
Marie
it was either him or his little buddy
serial killer is nothing more than a
serial rapist all right they just happen
to kill the victim you know and then
eventually they start getting into
killing the victim but that's basically
what it is it's a serial rapist now they
usually start killing the victim after
they have close calls with the law or
maybe they do a few years for indecent
exposure or rape they get out ago that's
it I'm killing them yeah
they're not gonna testify against me
that's use that does well yeah that's
that's your escalation right there so I
think that's what makes me leads me to
believe this guy really hadn't been
doing this for very long I think the
media kind of blew him up into more than
what he really is well I mean that's
pretty horrifying that somebody would
spend all that time and money making a
trailer it's just a torn yeah yeah but
we're talking about body count how many
did he kill I'm not convinced he killed
anybody
yeah I don't know but like I said they
know they're pretty sure that Murray
Parker got killed but they don't know if
it was him or he the husband was in on
it
chances are the husband did it no I
don't even know you're talking about me
see there was a murder on the periphery
to where a guy killed his wife and then
the the offender knew about it no I've
been drinking but I don't know who
killed who in this case you said
somebody killed somebody
yeah Murray Parker who is the dog he was
no no she was the ex-girlfriend of David
Parker raised buddy like a friend of his
okay yeah and that guy yeah Dennis yeah
he said that ray told him to kill Murray
Parker so you strangled her that's what
he said he confessed that's why he got
250 others others the other guy did it
right yeah yeah that's what he said but
he said that ray told him to do it
just cuz guy tells you to do it doesn't
mean well now she had been in the
trailer for three days and they'd been
torturing and raping her but then David
Parker ray says to Dennis hey killer
right and I'll kill you if you don't
that's if you ever tell anybody but
that's what he said
that's what I mean so I don't know you
know how seriously we take that they
never did find her body but you know so
I said that's weird why can't they find
these bodies they're the ones that are
disposing these bodies where the hell
are they yeah what are the sands
shifting so they can't find the exact
location I don't know I'm like I said
it's kind of a big remote area and
there's a big body of water
like I said he was like a state park
worker so he knew all the byways and
mountains and [ __ ] like that so it's
like yeah it's easy to say but it's like
[ __ ] they could be anywhere the bodies
could be anywhere if he dumped him out
in the mountains or something like that
they never [ __ ] find him say just be
bones now so you know so it's possible
like I said investigators think it's
possible that he may have killed as many
as 60 people just judging by people that
went missing you know other reports his
accomplices saying various things about
him in some you would think he would've
fessed up to all of them if you decided
getting 200 years yeah I think you want
a grand stand there's no so yeah let's
take a break right now and when we come
back we will talk about yet another
scumbag this one there sure actually
killed a bunch of people that'd be
Christopher Wilder the so-called beauty
queen killer I know this one so we'll be
back in just a few minutes okay
everybody ginnis got some new shirt
designs up four of them really good ones
to Atlanta Ripper who put Bella in the
which out the HH Holmes murder castle
and of course demon child cuz man said
he could these are updated designs I
think they look really cool Jenny did a
great job Atum where they found making
Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out very good
yeah it really good they're very
high-quality shirts Jenny and I we're
sure our own shirts at certain times
when we're trying to put spotlight on
ourselves and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
on these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them mix in the description
WW sizzle calm at 13 o'clock yes ago
check out our store at wwl calm slash 13
o'clock we got these four cool new
t-shirt designs plus all our old ones if
you'd rather get one of the old ones but
these ones are awesome and you should
check them out they're also available in
women's cut they look really cute JT's
got some so thank you go check them out
she's trying to catch the bubbles
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century vol 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format right we're back
talking about these [ __ ] scumbag
serial killers yes I think so yeah this
guy I remember hearing about this guy on
[ __ ] I know I think I saw a
documentary about him like a really
really long time ago cuz this happened
like way back in the 80s and there was
also a made-for-tv movie about this guy
called easy prey yeah it's actually on
youtube if you want to look it up I
watched some of it the other day Gerald
McRaney playing Christopher Wilder the
second killer yeah who actually spookily
looks a lot like himself
yeah this guy's kind of like a kind of
like a wannabe what was his name Ted
Bundy kind of like I would want to be
Ted Bundy yeah they're their modus
operandi is very much yeah he's kind of
a kind of a good-looking photographer
well okay that's true he was
good-looking as body body was Bundy was
the Playgirl centerfold of [ __ ]
scissors yeah if they ever do just goes
to show it doesn't matter if you're
good-looking you know they don't they
don't come out looking like a particular
thing they don't they just look like
everyone else but yeah so this guy I
actually mentioned him briefly on the
show that we did about the Wanda beach
murders in Australia because he's
considered a suspect for that because
the killing of the two girls Mary Ann
Schmidt and Christine sherek that is
very similar to his later MO and he was
in the area at the time because he was
actually born in Australia his mother
was Australian his father was a United
States naval officer um he didn't have
like a real unusual childhood he wasn't
abused as far as I know he was very
sickly he was very sickly from when he
was born they actually when he was born
they thought he was going to die but he
actually did pull through and he made it
but you know like I said he was just a
real sickly kid but oven that nothing
super weird but then when he got into
his teenage years he started doing [ __ ]
like you know peeping tom type stuff you
know that kind of thing so you could see
that he was kind of heading for trouble
when he was 17 years old and like I said
this is the thing that brought him to
the attention of authorities for the
Wanda beach murders because it's very
similar he was 17 and about him and a
bunch of his friends actually gang raped
a girl on a beach in Sydney Australia
and he was arrested mahoma you can get a
bunch of friends together and go do this
[ __ ] that's what I mean and that's like
what the last guy it's like you just get
people to go along with you I don't
understand that it's a weird [ __ ] I
don't understand that at all that lead
content tell you I honestly I think if
you have like I said I think there's a
lot of factors but that's probably a
really big I mean not in the Western
world I mean you know I mean there are
certain cultures were [ __ ] like that
halves but not around here yeah II don't
just yesterday Australia's the civilized
world we talk about kata-kata the
civilized world
they might dispute your kind
badass cars though yeah
but yet so again he gets somebody who's
like hey let's get raped his girl was
like yes beau so so yeah they do that he
gets arrested now I guess because he was
a minor he he pleaded guilty so they
gave him a year probation he had to go
to counseling and they gave him a
lecture shock therapy
because yeah they're trying to shock it
out of it this was back in the sixties
yeah so evidently this made him worse
because he kind of like got off on it
and then he was like oh I can shot girls
and he like got off on the idea of like
shocking women that he was having sex
with you know electric shock so yeah so
that was like something and he sat with
something that he would do later on
- okay but so lunch or shop there appiah
didn't work nicholae not in this case
all right let's hear more of us so yeah
now he got a little bit older he's in
his early 20s now he did get married do
you know how long that marriage lasted
eight days she found out about his [ __ ]
she was like bye and she took the [ __ ]
off he also got in trouble for some
other you know I don't want to say minor
[ __ ] but you know he was trying to lure
women to pose naked for him you know
other kind of [ __ ] like that but nothing
that really got any charges pressed
against legal so far yeah I mean it's
illegal but if they don't press charges
then there's nothing to do about it so
he had been to the US when he was a kid
because like I said his dad was an
American so in 1969 he decides he's
going to emigrate to the United States
and he moves there and he moves to
Florida
so he's like Florida man man yeah this
guy's floor mad max' Florida man this is
like Florida man to the 10th power
that's great yeah now he actually he
wasn't a loser like he had a good
business like he did construction and
electrical work he got into real estate
so he had a couple mill you know what I
mean he wasn't poor he had a really nice
house you
likes flashy cars and you know fades
expensive watches and all that kind of
crap so he's got all that going for him
and yet he still can't stop himself from
doing this [ __ ] scumbag II [ __ ]
because he just so 1971 which is only a
couple years after he moved to the US
someone he again was trying to like lure
women into posing naked for him and like
trying to force her to pose naked he got
turned in by the victim that time but
they didn't take it all that seriously
so he just got a fine and they let him
go then he his next thing like I said
escalation he was in a house doing like
renovation cuz like I said he had a
construction business and he forced a
high school student to perform oral sex
on him damn and she went to the cops oh
yeah so good for her now they arrested
him and he actually did go to trial but
they basically here's what he said that
he didn't think that he had done
anything wrong kind of thing um he just
thought it wasn't that big a deal or you
know he wanted her so it was fine yeah
so the judge was like well they had a
psychiatrist like look at him and
they're like well I don't think he
should be let out because they said he's
not safe in an unstructured environment
that was the terminology they used and
they had another psychiatrist come and
they're just like okay well he needs
serious therapy he needs to be put like
I'm imagining they wanted to put him
like in a mental institution because
they thought he had some real problems
so he so Christopher Wilder he tries to
get his lawyer to like make a deal or
just like go to the hospital or anything
like that but the case went to trial
anyway but then he got acquitted so he's
back out again on the street so he seems
to have not done anything too terrible
for the next
three years but that one was an actual
rape now this is when and like I said if
you've seen there's a very famous
documentary about him there was a
made-for-tv movie that came out I think
in 1986 about him this is like his
standard mo he goes around saying that
his name is David Pierce he goes to
malls and he approaches pretty young
women or you know young teenagers tells
them that he is a fashion photographer
and they are the most beautiful girl
ever you know sometimes he gives them
money like I'll pay you to do a photo
shoot bla bla bla and then he tries to
like lure them out to his car like come
see my portfolio or come to this place
where I can take pictures of you or
whatever yeah the dude with the camera
you always got to do with the camera
well watch any deal watch it really yeah
that comes up to you and starts talking
to you there's a whole trope and the
club scene of to do with the camera no
so now they're not all bad we gotta we
gotta do the camera now that's back in
the day though everybody's got a camera
their phones a camera yeah so it's not
like but back in the 80s yeah girls I
mean if you're walking around in the
mall with your cool foofy hair your big
shoulder pads new to the camera and some
dude comes up the camera it's like hey
you're so beautiful can I take a picture
of you answer is no run but the problem
is that even the girls that did that he
would usually get them anyway yeah but
yes right so he would find a way around
it so it wasn't even just like hey [ __ ]
off check that sometimes did not work
either so yeah so same thing he goes in
he says I'm a photographer you purchas
actually two girls are just as two girls
now he approached no I said he
approached them dummy so he goes up to
two girls one of them says nah man and
flake [ __ ] off um the other one was like
okay whatever so she goes out to the
parking lot he drugs her and then rapes
her in his truck she also went to the
cops and turned him in now again this is
the luckiest [ __ ] ever he's
going around like [ __ ]
using himself raping people [ __ ] like
that he goes to trial and then he gets
it plea bargained down to like I think
you got probation like he said I'll go
to sex therapy or something yeah right
he's like he gets out yeah so 71-72
yeah yeah this is like early seventies
so like I said I guess they really
didn't early seventies uh there was a
bad prison over overcrowding problem at
that time they were I think even some
states are just letting guys out yeah
some of those guys had committed murders
and they were led about yeah yeah bad so
that's for yeah that's probably the case
what happened here so he said yeah I'm
just gonna go see his sex therapist I
don't really know what I'm doing I just
I have blackouts and I don't know what's
gone so they whatever so they let him go
to therapy and blah blah now he goes
back to Australia to visit his parents
and this is years later this is like in
1982 now while he was in Australia like
I said he couldn't [ __ ] help himself
he grabbed two fifteen-year-old girls on
a beach forcing them to pose naked for
pictures and then force them into like
subservient positions and masturbated on
them this is very very similar to the
Wanda Beach murders case although like I
said in that case obviously the two
girls were murdered these ones were not
but this was the same thing that
happened at Wanda Beach the two girls
were teenagers and they hadn't been
raped but they had like semen on them
dude's got serious balls man yeah yeah
you just do this [ __ ] with impunity well
the thing about this guy that is always
fascinated me and like I said I think I
saw this [ __ ] documentary about him
like back in the [ __ ] 80s or 90s and
I was just like what this was like
really freaked me out because you know
is the 80s Mall culture it's like you
know everybody hung out at the mall and
it's like some creep comes up and like
suddenly [ __ ] rapes and murders you
yeah but the thing that fascinates me
the most about him is that even though
it's like he couldn't stop himself like
even when the [ __ ] FBI was chasing
him even
he just like still gotta do is just like
it kept going to balls and picking girls
up and like raping him and shooting man
this this was his sexual orientation
again literally this was his sexual
organ yeah I guess that's one way of
putting it this was his what they called
a date he identified as this this is
what he was yeah I guess but like I said
it's like he couldn't even stop himself
even when he was in trouble and he was
getting a cot it's just like seems
really stupid maybe he was suicidal I
don't know but that was smarter than
everybody else knew he'd get away with
it yeah he was just trying to go from
one fix to the next anybody that thinks
there's so he gets arrested in Australia
for because the two girls of course like
rent immediately ran to the police it
was like please pick this creep up so
his parents paid his bail and evidently
they didn't have any problem with him
leaving the country and going back to
his house in Florida so you know okay so
at this stage I think this is where and
this is where his substantial they call
him a serial killer it was almost like a
spree like what he did because it was
only like three or four months like a
period of three or four months and he's
like driving around the country just
going to malls and picking girls up and
[ __ ] it was just like I'm believing
well he raped some of them too it's like
you know what I mean but that that
particular one where he just like
masturbated on them that reminded me
very much of Wanda Beach which is
probably why he's a suspect in that
although they're never gonna know
because he's dead now but he was a
jackoff artist yeah I guess so I know so
all right so this jack hole comes back
to Florida and immediately like starts
this [ __ ] spree right yeah he picks
up he goes to the merits square shopping
mall he picks up a girl named Terry
Ferguson she was 21 years old so she had
been seen around the mall she had been
wandering in the mall and you know he
came up to her and said hey
you know a photographer you're beautiful
blah blah blah
and then they and then she disappeared
now the her stepfather went to the mall
and found her car still parked there so
they were freaking out and they like
call the police and stuff like that now
an hour after the last sighting of her
Christopher Wilder he actually got his
car stuck in the sand and had to call a
tow truck so the tow truck comes out
there and they note that this car is
where the cars parked it's like a known
Lovers Lane but he is by himself so they
thought that was a little odd so they
asked him what are you doing out here he
said oh I just got lost he ended up
paying for the tow truck with his
business partners credit card which they
later found out was stolen hmm um but
they didn't know that at the time so he
went on his way
five days later there there was a body
found about 70 miles west of where Terry
Ferguson lived in a canal and this was
identified as the body of Terry Ferguson
so when this when they found the body
all the people like from the mall that
had seen her they said oh yeah we saw
her talking to this guy and they
described a guy that looked very much so
that's the this is the first death
associated that they know of yeah he
went from peeping tom and he was a
teenager too you know just sexual
assault yeah
rape that's the typical escalation
that's typical pretty much it's safer to
kill him so that's what they do cuz they
don't wanna get caught yeah so I can't
stop it's compulsive yeah you know yeah
and in case I didn't mention it that was
a that was end of March 1984 so his next
victim was from Tallahassee and she was
kidnapped from a shopping mall near
Florida State University now he actually
left her in a motel what he would do and
this is what I was thinking of before
when I was thinking about David Parker
ray when he would do is he would take
him to a cheap motel he would tie them
up or tie them to the bed he would
superglue their eyelids shot damn and he
had this
thing where he would rig up like copper
wire and stuff soon he was like shocked
their feet remember like I said yes he
was into electroshock therapy and that
was like how he got off yeah and then he
would rape them multiple times plug it
into the wall yeah
I'm assuming that that's how that went
yeah 110 volts I kill you yeah so he was
just like shocked two bottoms their feet
so he yeah so he would like take these
four girls to motel rooms and rape them
in there and do various things now this
girl she was 19 years old now at this
point they the FBI got involved because
he kidnapped her and then he took her
over the state line he took her into
Georgia so yeah now she actually got
away because the weird thing about him
is that a lot of people said that he was
super super into like TV like he would
just sit there and like stare at the TV
and he'd get all like into in [ __ ] so
they're in the hotel room that night and
he's like raped and tortured this girl
over the previous few hours and then he
gets all into something on TV and she
starts thinking maybe I could like
escape you know what I mean so she
starts kind of creeping toward the edge
of the bed and like she kind of gets
loose and she jumps out of bed he goes
they have like a struggle and she's like
able to push him off and she runs in the
bathroom and locks herself in and then
she starts screaming her head off and
banging on the walls and [ __ ] like that
so that you know people in the other
hotel rooms can hear her and this
apparently freaked him out so bad that
he just gathered all his [ __ ] and left
good place so yes so good for her like I
said that was a [ __ ] brave but I
guess she probably thought well he's
gonna kill me otherwise yeah you got
nothing yeah so she so she like dude was
banging on the wall stuff and then she
stayed in the bathroom for like half and
because she thought he was still out
there and just like being quiet you know
so she just like stayed in there and
stayed in there finally she like snuck
out and she went to the hotel manager's
office
she didn't have any clothes on she just
had like a bedsheet and she was all like
her hair was all bloody and [ __ ] like
that and she said what had happened so
she was actually able to tell the police
like what kind of car he was driving and
all this other kind of [ __ ] so they
could put out like an APB and like I
said at this point the FBI was become
involved they had suspected him in some
of these missing-persons cases prior to
this but because he had taken her over a
state line now the FBI could step in
you know officially but they had been
investigating him kind of like off the
record for a little bit before this um
so they got the name I don't know if he
registered under his real name or if it
was a fake name I think he actually
registered at the motel under his
business partners name because he was
using that guy's credit card but they
gave it they had a description of him
and stuff like that all his stuff was
gone from the hotel room but they did
find like bloodstains all over the wall
and [ __ ] like that um so she said she
told police the same thing and like he
had come up to her and said hey I'll
give you $25 an hour and she said he
seemed like she said he didn't seem like
a creep like he seemed really nice he
wasn't pushy you know he was very
well-dressed he had like a really nice
suit and [ __ ] like that um and she said
I wasn't gonna go with them but then I
decided oh he's probably alright because
he didn't seem creepy or dangerous um so
but the thing is she says she goes out
with him to carks he's like oh I've got
like my portfolio out of my car in the
parking lot and he starts showing her
like all these magazines oh I took this
picture and I took that picture and then
she started getting kind of nervous and
she's like okay yeah never mind I'm just
gonna go but then he punched her and so
she wasn't gonna go with him but he made
her go anyway so you know what I mean so
he like just punched her in the stomach
and punched her in the face and shoved
her in the car and took off so and she
hadn't didn't know where she was because
she had like duct tape over her face and
everything like that so she had actually
been in the hotel for several days like
you know been raped and tortured and I
think he like he shaved her pubic hair
off it's like he would hold the knife to
her vagina it's like how does this make
you feel he did all that kinda crap
it's like [ __ ] up so oh another thing
another thing he did to was he had like
I said he was TV obsessed like it was
the 80s so he finds like a show with
like a bunch of girls doing aerobics and
he made her do that made her do the
aerobics yeah
even there her eyes were glued shut and
she was all beat up and everything yeah
and if she didn't do it right he would
shock her feet
I'm like just man horrible so yeah so
the next one was actually in Texas so
he's like I said he's driving all over
the place he's just driving and I think
at some point he stopped at a bank cuz
they got his stupid ugly mug on the
[ __ ] bank camera or whatever and he
took out like $19,000 or something like
that so he was clearly they think that
he was probably trying to leave the
country but he was like going out in a
blaze of glory I guess yeah cuz he was
like just everywhere he stopped he would
kidnap somebody who's doing this like
there's no tomorrow problem because yeah
there was no tomorrow that's kind of the
impression that I'm getting like they
they don't know if he knew that he
wasn't gonna make it or if he was
actually trying to get out of the
country so like if he'd wanted to get
out of the country you think he would
have headed right for it instead of
taking this circuitous route I think
he's one of those guys it was kind of
just kind of going headlong out of
control it did yeah it did seem like you
know what was gonna happen from one day
to the next he was just gonna ride the
train ya know wherever it took him yeah
and he probably thought that it was he
was gonna die in a blaze of glory
against the cops probably thought was
gonna happen yeah what which is kind of
how it wasn't a blaze of glory but yeah
he did um the next victim was Terry
Walden she was 24 years old she was a
nurse she was actually married and had a
couple of kids now she had told her
husband apparently Christopher Wilder
had approached her several days before
he kidnapped her asking if she would
model for him and she said no and then
like he kept like bugging her about hey
come out to my car and she's just like
no man leave me alone and she she had
accreted creeped her out so she told her
husband about it but then he didn't
really think anything of it when she
disappeared like a couple days later
like he didn't remember her saying that
so they found her body a couple days
later she was floating facedown in a
canal she had actually not been raped
but it looked like
you know she'd been tied up and beaten
and stabbed a bunch of times so I don't
know if you know it was a situation
where it looked like he hadn't been able
to do what he did with a lot of the
other victims which was like keep them
in a hotel room for an extended period
of time
she had all her clothes on you know so I
don't know she fought him and he just
ended up stabbing her and dumping her I
don't know so like I said at this point
FBI are involved they he's like
switching cars cuz he's like taking some
of the victims cars so they're kind of
trying to stay on his trail at some
point they put him on the top ten
fugitives list so they could splash his
face and make a car like all over the TV
March 25th he kidnapped a girl named
Suzanne Logan she was 21 this was an
Oklahoma City same thing in the mall now
she had dropped her husband off at work
at the mall and then he was the one that
report her missing because she didn't
come back to pick him up she had
actually they found her the same day
that they found teri walden floating in
a reservoir she had been tortured and
raped and had been stabbed to death she
this was another thing to where he
shaved off the pubic hair he cut off her
hair she had like really long blonde
hair
he had cut off all her hair and they
later found it like in a motel room
trash can so that's where he'd been
keeping her um the next one happened in
Colorado that was Cheryl Bonaventure uh
she was 18 she was also kidnapped from a
mall the Grand Junction Mall several
witnesses saw a man that they described
looking like Christopher Wilder they saw
them together and said that he had been
soliciting women at the mall so he
wasn't like it's done because I think at
this point he knew that they were
looking for him but he doesn't seem to
be making any effort to like disguise
his face or change up his MO or anything
he's just stopping at shopping malls and
doing the same [ __ ] he always does yeah
we're like trying to get girls to come
out to the car and then whacking him
over the head he's trying to get that
next girl yeah it's just when it's like
him yeah it's only like a couple days
like in between and he's just like
driving in the
every time he stops he goes to humble
like he can't help himself like I saw a
sex addict yeah so Cheryl Bonaventure uh
she went missing she was not found until
much later on in the meantime
Christopher Wilder turns up in Las Vegas
now this was the case that I remembered
the most because this creeped me out um
there was a mall in Las Vegas and they
were having like a fashion show
Seventeen magazine was having a little
Fashion Show there and they were having
like a model search or whatever so
there's this girl Michelle korfin she
was 17 years old and she was at this
particular fashion show and went missing
that same day
now they suspected you know the FBI
suspected that Christopher Wilder was
behind this so they asked anybody that
was at that Fashion Show to please turn
in any photographs they might have taken
at this Fashion Show and one of the
photographs showed Michelle Kaufmann up
on the runway like with her little
fashion outfit on and right down there
in the seat looking right at her was
Christopher Wilder and I was like that
is some creepy ass [ __ ] right there and
I found the photo online too because and
he's just like looking at her like all
creepy and Wow
so yeah that's kind of horrible so like
I said at this point he's been added to
the ten most wanted list his [ __ ]
face is all over the TV but they're
having a hard time catching him because
you know he's not he doesn't seem to be
going in a particular direction because
at first they were like well maybe he's
heading for Mexico so he doesn't get
extradited but then he's like starts
heading back east again like you know
what I mean and he keeps like switching
cars switching license plates you know
he's using a stolen credit card or
several stolen credit cards sometimes
using cash so they're having a hard time
finding him this was 1984 it's not like
yeah they can't like paying yourself
today yeah so it's it's not like that so
they kind of have you know they did like
a little bit of a profile on him saying
like I said he had more of a he had kind
of a Ted Bundy quality he had more
qualities of a spree killer actually
rather than a serial killer just because
you know he's going around doing this
like it was an addiction like he
couldn't stop himself so you know they
one creepy thing too is that in the
process of trying to get like a better
profile on him they started interviewing
like people that he knew and they
actually found a videotape I guess he
had made remember like those old timey
like dating services or he'd make like a
video tape of yourself like talking
about yourself like that they would show
to other people that came into the
dating agency know tell us all about it
Jenny no I'm just saying they're from
the 80s they had that kind of show yeah
I heard about it yeah I heard about her
it was kind of like a video rental store
yeah
I never ship and go in there and you see
all these videos up with people with
women's or whatever people's photographs
on them and you check them out took him
home and you watched it yeah
asked those people to go on a date with
you type of deal yeah it seemed like I
saw him on like TV shows and stuff like
that they in in Boston I had dating
services that were like that yeah I
think that's what this was it was kind
of like they were kind of like
blockbuster this blockbuster buster for
dating for date I would like to rent a
person please
it's like sander 3d [ __ ] wasn't cheap
either
yeah but he actually he had made a
videotape for one of these dating
services back in 1981 and they said that
on the tape he like talked a bunch about
himself which probably shouldn't but he
said he wanted a long relationship but
not marriage and he said he was looking
for a woman of depth and sincerity like
okay all right buddy
he also indicated that he preferred
women in their early 20s even though he
was he was in his 30s at this point so
he wasn't like it wasn't that creepy
like he wasn't like he was 70 or yeah I
guess so now here's okay now this part's
really disturbing so the next victim
that he kidnapped was a 16 year old girl
named Tina Marie
Rasika now he kidnapped her from a mall
she wasn't there bottling or anything
like that she was there filling out a
job application I think it Hickory Farms
or something so he comes up to her he
says hey I'll give you $100 let me take
pictures she's kind of reluctant but
finally she goes along with him so he
actually took her to a place and was
like taking pictures of her and stuff
but then like when she turned back
around he was pointing a gun at her face
and he like you know forced her into the
car now the weird thing about this is
that for whatever reason he decided that
he wasn't going to kill her but that he
was going to make her help him pick up
other victims
I remember this poor girl is 16 years
old now she got raped and tortured and
all the usual [ __ ] that he would do like
you know he would take her to hotel and
do all that stuff but for some reason
there was something about her that
thought that would make it easier for
him to pick up victims I mean she's
probably really applying maybe that's
what it was so yeah but she actually
ended up living but this is kind of like
I I couldn't I couldn't imagine like
living with this kind of [ __ ] because
you know she people had seen her at
first the cops were like oh she just ran
away and bla bla bla but then finally
they figured out oh probably this
[ __ ] has her so he makes her go
and pick up this other 16 year old girl
whose name was done at wilt and this was
a Gary Indiana so like I said they're
driving all over the [ __ ] place place
is a wasteland now yeah well yeah so
Donna is in Gary Indiana filling out a
job application and this other sixteen
year old girl who was Tina Marie risiko
comes up to her and says can you come
outside you know to speak to the store
manager and the store manager
quote-unquote was Christopher Wilder so
he grabs da net like forced her into the
car with a gun and then he takes them
both to a motel and then Tina Marie is
just like having to sit there watch him
like raping and torturing this guy
girl while she just sits there and can't
do anything about it
well 16 a person's very young of course
oh yeah press table she's probably
terrified well yeah yeah total mind
control over her yet out she did because
you know I think a lot of people later
on we're kind of like cuz a couple times
like he left her alone in a car and said
well why didn't you run away and [ __ ]
like that it's a five yes she was
probably [ __ ] terrified as you would
be because he told her don't you dare
try to escape while killing they
believed him like a rabbit in the
headlights right and like I said there
were only 16 for Christ's sake that's
just like that's a little kid so yeah
and so what he does he drives out to
these woods and he leaves Teena Marie in
the car
but then he takes da net like out into
the woods and he first sure like tried
to suffocate her strangle or something
like that and that didn't work so
anything he stabbed her like front and
back and then just left her now like I
said Teena Marie was left in the car but
she didn't run away because she was like
terrified so he drives off for a little
bit and then he thinks oh maybe I should
go back and make sure she's dead because
I only stabbed her two times and maybe
that wasn't sufficient so he drives back
to where he stabbed the girl and she was
gone she took off she was able to get up
and get to the road and she got help so
again good for her um so yeah cuz he was
gonna go back and shoot her but she got
the [ __ ] out of there so after that like
even that did not deter him he just like
keeps on going you know he keeps on
going
next time he ends up in [ __ ] East View
Mall this is in Victor New York that's
driving everyone he's just yeah like I
said he's just going everywhere
he gets Teena Marie to go and lure this
woman who was actually 33 so a little
bit older than his usual target her name
was Beth dodge and she was just getting
out of her car in the parking lot and
they said hey can she said hey can you
come over here for a minute and when she
came over there like he for [ __ ] in the
car at gunpoint and then he didn't even
rape her anything he just took her car
like he just took her to a gravel pit
and shot
and then just took her Trans Am and then
yeah she wasn't hot enough to rape so he
just killed her I guess yeah 33 that's
so yeah yeah she was over the hill right
I guess so
and then at this point like after he
steals the car and he's just shoots this
woman leaves her in a [ __ ] gravel pit
he drives to Logan Airport in Boston he
gives Teena Marie a bunch of money and
says buy a plane ticket home hmm and get
a cab you must have felt sorry for in
some way yeah she said later on like
when she was talking to the police she
said that he told her that I don't want
you around when I die so I think that he
knew yeah that it was all coming to a
head and she said she was I mean like I
said this poor girl and she actually you
know I know it wasn't her fault but I'm
sure she probably thought it was her
fault that she like contributed yeah
she's probably the survivor's guilt you
know yeah like you would never get over
baby listen and you were only 16 little
young yeah it wasn't her fault I really
really hope you yeah your brain isn't
well-formed at that time and [ __ ] you
know you you're ply you do what you're
told at 60 and I'm telling you too that
it's like and particularly women
particularly young women we think
everything is our fault anyway even [ __ ]
that can't conceivably be our fault yeah
um
so he kept her alive because she was a
deer in the headlights he was yeah that
way but yeah she you know there was
really there was nothing she could have
done a girl at 16 totally defenseless in
the face yeah it's like he was armed he
had knives and guns and he was molded
yeah you know he would have killed her
I'm sure he would I be if she didn't why
he killed her yeah so you know I don't I
don't blame her at all but she said it
was sad because she's like even when I
was like walking to the airport like to
go get on the plane she's like I was
sure that he was just gonna come up and
shoot me in the back you know she's like
I didn't really believe that he was
gonna levitate but she did she whoa
um so at this dis so he's so his little
you know the the victim that he had
there that was using to get other
victims you know he let her go then
was April 13th he tried to get another
girl who was 19 her car had broken down
she was just like standing on the side
of the road Christopher Wilder rolls up
and says hey I'll give you a lift to get
gas and she's like yeah thanks she gets
in the car and then he passed the gas
station and she was like what are you
doing and then he pulls a gun on her and
she jumped the [ __ ] out of the car she
like she just jumped out while I was
moving and rolled and whatever now at
this stage he drives to New Hampshire
and stops at a service station in
Colebrook this is about 12 miles from
the Canadian border so they think that
he probably was trying to cross into
Canada while he was talking to the
attendant because I think he asked the
attendant about you know what all
paperwork am I gonna need to cross the
border in blah blah blah there were two
cops at the service station and they
recognized the car because it had
belonged to one of the victims and they
said hey that's that guy that everyone's
looking for like they recognized him so
they started talking to this like okay
well we got to do something about this
so the they get out you know they they
pulled out alongside him they called out
his name he dives inside the vehicle
which assuming he's trying to get his
gun cuz he's gonna like shoot at the
cops and one of the troopers like jumps
on the guy's back you know what I mean
and grabbing for his gun and two shots
went off now the trooper was shot in the
liver he actually ended up surviving the
other shot went right through
Christopher Wilders heart and exploded
it what heart that [ __ ] didn't
have that's our yeah where his heart
yeah but at any rate it killed him
instantly good riddance you piece of
[ __ ] right so he died on Friday the 13th
47 days since the first reported
disappearance 26 days on the run yeah so
yeah this guy and
[ __ ] they found like the obviously they
found guns am a rope tape all that kind
of [ __ ] in his car
they also found what was his favorite
book the collector by John foul okay so
that takes us back to [ __ ] Leonard
Lake yep yep it's about an entomologist
he collects butterflies and stuff like
that and he decides he's gonna collect a
person so this beautiful woman named
Miranda that he's in love with and he
decides he's gonna kidnap her and he's
gonna treat her nice but she can't leave
like she's his prisoner and it's this
kind of [ __ ] up story and for some
reason like guys with this type of
personality personality really in really
into this book and he had a copy of it
in his car like when they went through
all his [ __ ]
so yeah loser [ __ ] dot yeah that's what
I mean but that it's just weird and like
I said you know when we did the show
about Leonard like yeah that was he was
into that book too like oh that's look
that's like their ultimate fantasy like
keeping a woman and like then gee we
can't earn a woman by their own merit
right so there's like one yeah for
cemented of course it's like I just have
to keep her locked up until she realizes
how awesome I am and then she falls in
love with me kind of and I'm like man
that's messed up I can't attract a woman
so you have to [ __ ] capture a woman
yeah that's exactly what it is and they
all seem to be doing that so [ __ ] up
so later on they actually ended up
finding some of the victims that had
gone missing that they hadn't found the
bodies they found Cheryl Bonaventure Oh
in Utah shot and stabbed and they also
found Michelle Kaufmann the 17 year old
who had vanished from the Las Vegas
shopping mall where she had been at this
17 fashion show and with the picture of
him looking at her yeah they found her
body as well yeah they also think that
he was linked to some other murders also
there was a girl that went missing from
Miami racetrack she worked there and
they think they had seen the two of the
people had seen the two of them together
he was a race car driver also like he
was a hobbyist and they suspect that he
probably killed her as well and as I
said they
also think he was a suspect in the Wanda
Beach murders from 1965 if memory serves
they found a girl who fits the profile
of one of his victims they found her
dead out of Desert
yeah and they think that maybe he took
her out there for a photo shoot
and if I can raped and killed her isn't
that the same guy probably because like
I said his official tally that they know
of is eight victims but they suspect
that he probably killed a lot more okay
well on the side there was another case
that I can remember associated with this
guy they found a pretty girl kind of
hang out of the wood that was hanging
out in a mall yeah she disappeared yeah
found her out in the middle of desert on
a big rock formation just her bones hmm
they think that he took her out there
for some kind of desert photo shoot
raped and killed her out there well that
might have been one of the ones that I
was just talking about like maybe that
one he took from Vegas or okay whatever
they did find her didn't specify whether
where they found the bodies when I was
thinking I was in a rock formation
Cheryl Bonaventure I was found in Utah
but they didn't say if it was a rock for
me it was like a pretty rock formation
you know where you would do a photo
shoot out of the desert and they thought
he had taken her out there for a photo
shoot and killed her yeah brunette and
she had done some modeling they actually
show ya some of the girls that he
kidnapped had done monitoring in the
past yeah so they I guess they wouldn't
have been quite as suspicious so someone
like coming up to them and all the ones
that survived said that he didn't seem
creepy right like he seemed normal and
he seemed really nice and he wasn't even
pushy or anything yeah so there's no
girl like I said I I feel like this guy
is interesting because not only because
he has aspects of both like spree killer
and serial killer but also even though
he's victim profile and his the way he
picked up his victims was always the
same he didn't always kill them the same
like some of them were shot some were
stabbed some were strangled or
suffocated or whatever um and some of
them he just liked that one woman Beth
dodged he just killed her because he
wanted her
like he didn't even do anything - he
just took her to a gravel pit and shot
her in the back or well there wasn't a
true victim she was way what do you want
yeah he's a car and yeah he just
carjacked her so I mean just by looking
at those ages are the girls that he
killed he liked him young yeah they were
almost always teenagers he wasn't
attractive her early 20s I don't even I
don't think a guy like this was even
attracted to women who are hot who were
in their 30s yeah I don't understand it
I think I think women actually get
better-looking as they get older a lot
of times but they have guys like that
there's something with their psyche I
think it's probably have something with
their self-confidence they don't feel
they don't feel powerful around a mature
woman yeah they want to feel powerful
around young you know I do feel like
that so that's part of what is here a
lot of like it does seem like guys that
are into really a lot younger women than
men they can't manipulate a woman in
their thirties yeah I think that's
exactly what it is they want to like
lord it over somebody or feel like they
have power over somebody and they feel
like they can't do that with someone
that's the same age as them like it's
more like they're equal like they can't
deal with it so I do definitely feel
like this guy had that kind of thing I
could have also been the times in those
days if you looked at like Playboy
magazine and mainstream kind of
pornography it was younger women that's
what was being aimed at men and that's
what they were kind of fixating on you
know which was women in their prime
fertility which in their minds back then
they thought that was around 19 yeah but
nowadays it isn't so much the case I
mean you look at the porn history today
you know I mean still the most popular
ones you know in their forties milfs
milf milf porn is [ __ ] super popular
with you young man I know that was
something that I always found really
interesting because I think I mean I
guess since I like you I grew up in the
80s and stuff and it did seem like you
know I didn't know like a huge amount of
pore about porn but it did seem like
they were all like super young and so it
kind of interested me to see more modern
porn and how even like guys in their 20s
or like into porn stars that are like in
their 40s yeah well we we know people in
the club I mean you know remember that
young guy that was just just just in
love with you and oh that's right that's
right yeah what's his name again
oh I can't and he was young it was super
yeah he was 18 like 18 and he just
thought that [ __ ] you and I smile
yeah he was just in love with her yeah
he and he was it's funny because I mean
I've known some guys that were like 18
or 19 but seemed older he didn't know he
really been 18 like a very young yeah
person and his mom was he he joined the
military yeah he's in the army yeah I
thought I was in the army
I told him to join the army join the
army yeah
his mom was the same age as Sonja at
that time yeah that's what I was
thinking we was not a goofing on him IRA
cuz I remember talking to a woman he was
talking about his mom and I was like I
was like why your mom's the same age as
me probably he's like yeah Sonya Sonya
basically looks like a for like a like a
MILF porn star all that little skinny
you know and yeah young guys are into
that that's cool though yeah it's not
like it was cuz you know it's like
everybody's got something you know yeah
when I was 18 I was interested women in
their forties you weren't no no because
every woman I knew in the 40s back in
those days was well dumpy that's what I
mean it's not the way it what I think
it's different now because when we were
growing up like people that were in
their 40s looked old they looks very old
and they acted very old
yeah and they acted old and I think that
a lot to do with it that baby I see like
old people that acted like
yeah they thought like old people yeah
and they just they weren't sexy at all
yeah see I don't I mean maybe it's
because we're kind of like in the goth
scene and stuff and there's like a lot
of people in that scene that are in
their 40s or even 50s you men know you
wouldn't really know it yeah you know
what I mean because I'm not sure why
it's I guess because they retained their
youthful so we don't go in the Sun so we
don't we don't care right now yeah it's
the attitude to and plus it's hard to
tell how old somebody is when they dye
their hair bright blue you know I'm
saying and stay physically yeah so so I
feel like it's it's not really the same
as it used to be I really feel like the
days of like the quote-unquote
generation gap you know when they used
to talk about that this isn't much of a
generation not really because it's like
we we hang out with people like half our
age they're like we're people that are
older and it's like you know we have
like a lot in common like if you like
you know yeah we're in the same boat we
know more than them yeah we still have a
lot more in common yeah yeah it's and
it's just cuz they haven't really been
around like you don't know the bands and
they don't know yeah you could give them
like life advice and like advice about
older music that they might not know
about but they're I don't find them
difficult to talk to I mean they seem
pretty up on [ __ ] I think the internet
kind of changed everything
yeah it did it kind of equalized and
also younger people kind of have an
appreciation for 80s culture and stuff
that was happening so they yeah that's
the nice they know about it in general
yeah because I was like that a
forementioned 18 year old kid we were
talking about he knew everything about
the music knew all of the 80s songs all
of them like he would go to the 80s
night he knew every single song he knew
all the words he knew everything like
about all the bands and everything yeah
he was like he would talk about it like
it was ancient history that he's talking
about classical music yeah yeah I guess
you as it's like yeah I remember when
this video came out I was like several
years back now he's an old man in the
Army now yeah that was yeah yeah that
was a few years ago
yeah all right I guess we're gonna wrap
up the show I think we've said pretty
much all we need to say about these two
dirtbags yeah well like I said at least
they're both dead so you know it's weird
I don't hear about this happening
anymore
we always get back to that witty sure it
does but you know it doesn't go on for
that long
yeah and it's easier to catch them just
be easier to catch them and I don't
think they're there I don't think they
form as easily as they used to
yeah and you can't get away with that
kind of [ __ ] anymore
sure cell phone I think has changed a
lot but I also think it's the mentality
of the guys yeah I think and now I'm
gonna go back to what I said before I
think I had some dude leaded gasoline
yeah because I thought across the
program it's talking about all those
Arctic expeditions uh-huh and they're
mystified at some of the decisions that
were made by the people in charge these
expeditions so they went out there and
collected all the dead bodies some of
them were buried out in graves you know
out in the ice they found him dug them
up and some of those cases it's like
5,000 times the normal lead content
inside those bodies because they were
using lead to seal up the tin cans that
they were eating now yeah today we're
very contaminated with lead and they
weren't thinking oh yeah well it's only
a thousand miles let's go walk they
talked a little bit about that like on
the terror yeah that sure they had on as
one of ships
yeah ships was the terror and yet they
said that they did dumbass [ __ ] yeah
they were like hallucinating and like
just doing stupid [ __ ] they were like
going some of them went crazy yeah yeah
well I know that cold will make you
hallucinate you know I was in the Army
and up in Korea 50 degrees below zero
will make you hallucinate but when they
dubbed those dead bodies up the lead
content was [ __ ] amazing in some of
those guys so that was part of it and I
think back in the seventies the 60s 70s
and 80s that leaded gasoline yeah let it
gasoline was everywhere and it was
blowing around in all the cities and
they have been building up for decades
in some of those cities and I think lead
poisoning had a lot to do with crazy
shits on these guys did yeah it wouldn't
surprise me cuz like I said I mean not
that there's not people doing [ __ ] up
[ __ ] now it is cuz there is but it's not
like it was they were dumb I mean the
70s were like horrifying yeah
that was like I think that was like the
worst of it like I said and during the
time of the seventies there have been at
least 20 years now more at least thirty
thirty years of good dirt a good 30
years of [ __ ] lead build-up yeah
inside those cities blowing around
little lead particles yeah throw the
traffic it had to be something like that
like I said I'm sure that was a factor
yeah maybe even the major factor yeah I
remember buying leaded gasoline as a kid
yeah the choice team led II did not let
it that's not there anymore
yeah we're old kids were leaded would
win my car didn't need it
I was cheaper sometimes I remember
actually service stations where they'd
actually come out and fill up your car
with gas do like you didn't have to do
it yeah I think there's still some plate
there's still a couple states where they
have some of those but I think of maybe
New Hampshire I want to say or Vermont
or somewhere like that I think they
still have service stations I just seen
one of those my leaded gasoline angle I
never heard anybody talk about it I have
seen it mentioned I was I don't remember
where I read it might have been
Psychology Today or something like that
I was just reading something about
serial killers and that was just one of
like a list of factors yeah that they
mentioned like something about you know
lead poisoning in the environment or you
know whatever and like I said legalized
abortion that was another thing of you
know why why the crime dropped later on
because you weren't having people having
kids that they couldn't afford or that
they didn't want um you know so there
was less of that going on access
children yeah well and that's what I
mean I'm like I said it was less
children born into poverty less children
born that were unwanted or might have
ended up like in foster homes or in the
system or might have had like messed-up
childhoods because there they were
unwanted but a lot of these serial
killers don't come from backgrounds like
that
um well actually a surprising amount due
a surprising amount were um were abused
as children at least or neglected well
every now and then you get one with like
a normal childhood and they're just
messed up but it seems like the majority
of them had kind of messed up childhoods
I was just thinking that it's just weird
as [ __ ] the back on the day that they
just decided to put lead in gasoline
just because it could help a valve seal
a little bit better yeah you know I mean
in an engine and it kind of made an
engine run a little more quietly yeah
kind of a they didn't know what they
were doing but you know they said yeah
put some lead in that that can't
possibly go that engine down a little
bit it'll make the valve seal yeah it
did but I was poisonous yeah yeah well
you know back then they didn't really
think about that they were just like our
heart [ __ ] yeah that's fine I can just I
can drink gasoline there's nothing don't
happen to me like I said no such thing
as a good old days everyone was stupid
as [ __ ] yeah they were stupid States
looked like a second-rate third-world
nation through most of it
yeah when I was a little kid I remember
the country areas that Mississippi
looked very third-world yeah yeah man it
still looked like Mississippi but it was
wooden paneling on things you know I
mean and just cheap you know yeah
everything looked cheap everything
everything was cheap and brown cheap
yeah cheap paint things and yeah and and
you know there was the United States its
must be a first world country yeah and
it was you know 81 78 77 but I remember
it was just it was crappy yeah yeah it's
like now we see movies like brothers I
was like oh we love this [ __ ] we go
never have crap you remember that exact
furniture with the flick oh yeah [ __ ]
cows were out crappy that [ __ ] cow as
it gets
yeah it's funny cuz when I watch
stranger things they had like a bunch of
[ __ ] in their house that we
my house grown up like a lot of the
dishes we saw a bumblebee that was
taking place in the 80s the wood
paneling in the houses remember those
old houses like how dark they were yeah
I think that couch in there we had that
couch
and in in that that house in the movie
bumblebee that house would have been a
nice house for the 80s
yeah but you look at it now there's not
enough windows in that house that [ __ ]
[ __ ] darkest [ __ ] you know I mean
[ __ ] dark
it's really weird they didn't put much
no they didn't put many windows in
houses man yeah everything was like
really really dark not enough glass
I guess darkened Cana cheap feeling you
know low ceilings low ceilings weary of
looking shag carpeting dark shag like
brown shag carpeting we had green yeah
like green with gold flecks in it yeah
it was super classy wrap it up wrap it
up we're done all right
all right hope you enjoyed this latest
episode which was a hundred and twenty
eight and remember if you like the show
to like share subscribe and all your
social media if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
cast out more press calm and there's a
link in the sidebar to a PayPal account
um also check out our last movie review
which was the man with two brains also
check out our last matinee show which
came out on Sunday three new movies in
the theater and that will do it for this
latest installment and we will see you
next time
you
you